[Music]
I got listen I can't stop because now
everybody keeps ever since all this
kalila stuff went out more and more
stuff keeps being sent our way Marsh
okay
God she just it just keeps coming
um this is a this is a it's like dogs in
her care this is incorrect me if I'm
wrong
this is her while she was dating Bobby
propositioning Theo Von to eat her ass
actually I would see you would really
have to prove yourself I would not be
able to
um but that's okay that's all I want is
the chance to not be able to prove
myself that's all but you know what you
might if you were willing to because
Bobby doesn't eat ass at all and I love
it certain certain things that he
doesn't he's not into imagine your loved
one the person that you love your wife
your girlfriend your fiance goes on a
pot this one they're still going out by
the way goes on a podcast and does this
to you can you imagine like on purpose
like again I feel sympathy for people
who have like DMS leaked and [ __ ] like
that because that's [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] move kind of [ __ ] you know what I
mean
like when you know you're having a
private conversation and someone leaks
it or whatever yeah but you're going and
purposely going on a podcast and telling
people this myself
yeah about how Bobby doesn't like to eat
ass which by the way isn't that weird
some guys don't might I mean I do but
some guys don't if you were willing to
because Bobby doesn't eat ass at all and
I love it I love
certain certain things that he doesn't
he's not into so if you were inclined to
do stuff he wouldn't or fill some holes
I have a feeling that she's been
airtight more than once mm-hmm
okay you might I might consider
cohabitation oh wow okay so
see how fun just a normal dude like wow
that's [ __ ] weird of you to say to me
openly on this public pool bro it's not
even that somebody sent me messages and
listen I'm not going to give any details
up because I'm still in the process of
figuring out if they're real or not but
so far I'm leaning towards yes from
everything I've seen
Mark Harley was on Reddit on the fighter
and the kid read it and there was a
picture of him a picture of
um Kal Island theovonne I guess you know
whatever and Mark Carly refined like oh
wow a traitor and a [ __ ] talking about
Theo being a traitor which I'm starting
to feel
the reason that
and please guys some people know more
about this than I do but the reason that
Theo
from what I was told the the or from
when you could hear they talk about it
but the reason that Theo left the show
was because he could not get along with
Mark
and that would explain why Mark Harley
now has had Knives Out for Theo and
knives out for kalilah you know I'm
gonna end up Ironically in loving Mark
Carly because he's gonna be the one that
finally destroys Brandon's shop well the
problem is no one loves Mark Carly more
than himself
the brown coworker
I don't I'm not like a chronic I don't
love it all the time but like you know
three times a year oh yeah yeah yeah you
mean holidays holidays yeah yeah some
stuff I think around the holidays the
real real nice man especially if people
are having a shower now
you know but I like I don't know man
like Christmas presents and like you
know I will I love Theo you know
Halloween costumes and [ __ ] Theo [ __ ]
rules now
we played some of this episode on Friday
unfortunately merch or fortunately for
US Virgin point is the good stuff Virgie
pointed no no here's the thing because I
asked Virgie give me some time stamps
and he was like I can't
the whole video was a time stamp
so I just clicked to one of my favorite
moments that Virgie sent me thank you
Virgie by the way yeah you're welcome
buddy
um watch this [ __ ] weird merch watch
this
your kid hate me why does he hate Bobby
that's rough and why does he love me so
much he was he like jumped into your
arms honestly what
why does your kid hate me and then why
does he love cheese yeah I know she has
to just I don't give any bad energy to
that kid you give that energy to all
kids
bro again maybe if you're my wife I let
you get away with that a little bit but
I'll still [ __ ] shut you down in
public but to do that now you're not
even [ __ ] him and you're just gonna I
don't even know if she's trying to be
funny and she thinks it like just kalila
has never been funny on purpose I said
trying to be this is one of those times
you're gonna look back to this moment
and go okay maybe that maybe she was
right okay right okay look I'm just
saying kalila dual wields dog penises
like she's in Skyrim I'm trying to
figure this out all right bro just like
everybody else
what's the [ __ ] energy I give dude
you just I
Smiles hey baby what's up
Stan yeah baby you know I no I have a
good I pointed out photos of you after
that like the next day and then I so I
think he's gonna I think he's gonna love
you now wait wait so you put it off you
went online your name no no we were in
the park did you guys see the video no
he said do you look I'll show you you
saw my video okay sorry about that he
goes I'll watch your videos from now on
repeat
um so basically
um um I explained it for the audience
fancy pointed at a picture of you on a
poster it's really weird here and Tommy
was like Bobby no come on man watch the
videos I gotta watch it yeah let me see
let me see it I might this is gonna
wow
foreign
you know what I'm not gonna hurt your
kid ever
were you planning to before Bobby dude
look at the producer dude the Purdue by
the way Bobby's producer is my favorite
person he's the only guy that I like in
the entire in his show
I hope you weren't thinking about that
ever a little bit when they were crying
but like also Frozen is that you but it
was like screaming at me but like I love
your kid dude I was thinking of hurting
them too I was like this is a good job
here you better behave no let me ask you
squeeze his arm a little hard yeah can
we talk about the milestones yeah a baby
all right so can your baby stand oh
absolutely so when he stood for the
first time how'd you feel that was
pretty magical
I think now did you celebrate or what
happens
well I was worried that he probably was
like had done a few steps at daycare and
they never tell you because they don't
want to yeah that's true tell you like
oh all of his Milestones happened here
because he's spending more of his time
here than with you I don't want to say
anything rude because I like your kid
right but I make can I have a criticism
and I I I want to write a fine line here
and I'm going to be as we put a helmet
on him
weird but go on Bobby this gets odd this
gets really off the rails I'm just gonna
say I'm gonna let me ask you something
okay
your kid number one
well proportioned
what if somebody said that to me
I would never let them around my kid
ever again it's very strange I would be
like you're well first off anybody with
anybody with that mustache and [ __ ]
fingernails isn't going to be around
anybody's kids shouldn't be around yeah
we should be using any adjectives about
some of these kids unless they're
Behavioral
and and nobody should be making physical
compliments to people's kids outside of
the word cute hey your kid's cute I kind
of feel like there's a better way to say
horrible adorable rewarding adorable
adorable is the safest word but it's
like you know or or just say hey cute
kid you know what I mean it's a cute kid
let a little guy run around yeah you
don't want to go your kid has a nice
yams on them what your child is
aesthetically pleasing
even like your infant is precious
I I watched this this whole old ladies
are allowed to do that yeah and from I
swear to God this [ __ ] from now on every
Friday I'm watching the new tiger belly
I'm telling you bro it's [ __ ] the
more especially thanks to pod boy and
stuff like that the more you know about
the background too the weirder this gets
and I always look at that at kids
tell you why I like this producer the
reverse
I got you daily registered yeah yeah
here you go I've been here because he's
spending more of his time here than with
you I don't want to say anything rude
because I like your kid right but I make
can I have a criticism no that is not me
okay thank you frozen bye
see you later buddy that was the smoke
bomb there's a ninja there's a ninja I
heard the smoke bomb he's gone
and I I I want to write a fine line here
and I'm going to be as we put a helmet
on him because his head I know his hair
no I'm just going to say I'm writing a
fine line
over it yeah okay you're you're bro
you're like [ __ ] blasting through the
line like the Kool-Aid man yes
[Laughter]
I think okay
your kid number one
well proportioned and I always look at
that kids no
by the way by the way that was a gut re
that was a gut reaction you know that
was a gut like a kids kids no I don't
look at kids but just in terms of like
when I see a human I go are they well
proportioned oh yeah yeah I mean like
yeah no you are my head dude come on
you're not dude cut it cut it stop dude
yeah he's trying to you could tell his
producer's like I like my job I'm in
Hawaii for free can we please stop this
yeah come on man right do you think
you're well proportioned no I don't what
do you thinking do you think that your
chemicals are well balancing your brain
like please please please people in
[ __ ] brother [ __ ] houses shouldn't
be talking about anybody in any negative
way yeah that's how [ __ ] up kalila is
[ __ ] that [ __ ] didn't even register
to her no no to her it's fine but
remember she said what she said when she
was molested that she wanted to molest
somebody played that on the show
remember that
ill proportions proportionate what do
you mean all of it I think I have like
dwarf arms I think I have a um you know
bad taste in women bad judgment and
women
a beer guzzling belly you know I got
different aspects but I think that
happened over the years because when I
look at older pictures of you let me go
to the baby okay yeah wow think you know
what they're pictures let me go to the
baby right by the way you saw what you
do can you not no no I get it I get it
by the way this is the one time I'll
give you a kalila try to throw him a
life raft I'll give her like even even
by mistake she did but she did throw him
a life where I have to change the
subject right and he went back to no no
it's really important I tell you about
your sexy baby wait what no no we
already did the kid now I gotta do the
baby yeah like Bobby Fraser Bobby please
stop saying things like that and stop
referring it to us the sexy baby that's
really come on let me do this sexy kid
no don't say it that way
foreign
it's not any better when you watch this
whole stream and the entire time he's
talking about getting [ __ ] and like
looking for prostitutes I think
Philippines oh maybe or yeah I think I
don't know this is the honest truth cute
face
and I can tell he could be a handsome
One
why why are you doing this why are you a
virgin Asian man told you how handsome
your kids were would that go over well
well first of all I don't talk to Asians
second of all fair no no it wouldn't go
over well
he's got a bumpy [ __ ] head
take that out oh my God Bobby right it's
a big head oh it's a big head first off
I've called my head a [ __ ] head
many times because I can't find hats
that fit me I'm being serious I do have
a [ __ ] head you have one right now
yeah yeah because it's a flex fit it's
one of those that stretches oh yeah
cheat code for big [ __ ] heads
yeah that's not okay
when Royce goes to buy a fitted he has
to like it's like he has to pay extra
like I do for shoes actually awkward
size
kalila's problem
is not that he just said something weird
about a child's head or like is
critiquing the [ __ ] physical
appearance and he said she said
[ __ ] it said he said Mongol and
then she goes cut that out it's not your
show [ __ ] it actually it is that's true
it is ah you're right it is her show
sorry Bobby it's not your show [ __ ]
nope do you feel it all right so let me
say
Jesus we can edit right here we go right
your kid look at me beautiful face right
well proportioned body right yeah his
head
very big
that's but have you seen like that's
Korean and look at George's head so she
just makes fun of everybody she has she
ever perfect has she ever criticized
herself ever no
because the difference between the Bobby
Bobby at least makes fun of himself a
lot I've never heard her go I'm flawed
not only that I don't ever hear anybody
else go at her of course it almost feels
like it's like an Opie rule yeah no one
could no one's allowed to go after her
yeah that's all that's my only criticism
it but it's like
more big than
any other head I've seen as a baby 99th
percentile yeah wow yeah yeah you know
right giant computer yeah but I believe
that's true and I believe and that's the
point I'm gonna make okay
no it's it's not gonna look good but
he's gonna have a great job
it's a weird show huh this show is very
this shows the whole vibe is just off
it's almost like two x's you know
shouldn't be working together
um